so what's the dynamic what's the
juggling act like these days you know
y'all are all living together you got
two more in the bunch
dralin as well from time to time very
hectic it is very hectic trying to
keep them make sure lana's got in you
know doing what she needs to do and got
what she's got going on
and then
draylen he's a handful too
he's almost like my kid too yeah but
it's all good because like having the
tiny village and stuff i'm really
excited for alana because um
well when draylen first started coming
around
you know i mean he is a little bit older
um josh is also a little bit older than
me and that's obviously where the a lot
of backlash that they get um it is what
it is but i like draylen a lot the kids
love draylen josh loves raylen and to me
like
that's all that really matters
i don't care
about all the background noise his
family is so great they we spent
christmas with them we spent
thanksgiving with them
any type of birthday parties they've
always shown up they've always shown to
baby showers and stuff like that so at
least over the last year and seven
months they have been
very good to us they have treated us
just like family
that's awesome i'd love to hear that for
you alana so we we hear how much pumpkin
loves mr dralen here so what do you love
about him
oh i get this question
i never know what to say though what do
you enjoy about you know being with him
hanging out with him everything
everything
his personality i mean he drives you
everywhere too yeah
and um i like how like we could just
like it's never like quiet when we're
around like we're always talking about
something it's never just like an
awkward moment just like silence or none
of that yeah we're always just talking
about something has he been a great
support system to you he definitely has
what do you say though alana to folks
having you know all these opinions about
the age gap between you and jaylen in
our relationship the two most things
like everybody is always talking about
is our age gap and definitely because
like he's black and i'm white and we're
interracial couple um so those are the
two main things and like really i don't
care because like at the end of the day
my sister approves his mom approves and
we're happy so like what fans got to say
or what haters got to say i don't really
care it's like she's not getting married
she's not having kids she's doing very
good in school like
to me
and a lot of people don't realize too
like and i'm not saying this to like
down dragon or anything but they really
are on the same like wavelength you know
like
men take a little bit longer to mature
so well and elon has also lived a lot of
life exactly for her to only be like
almost 17.
alana has seen a lot done a lot a lot of
things so alana's very mature for her
age and also for me like me and i we
went to the same thing what are the
house rules though when draylen comes
over when alana has draylen over oh i
mean she already knows her rules she
ain't shutting no bedroom doors you
gonna sit out here and hang out with us
i mean jonathan's always been very
respectful about boundaries and stuff
that we've set here in our home and
outside of the home
um
they can go out and do as they plea you
know they can go out and go to
restaurants or go to the mall or
whatever as they please um
just like don't be coming in the door
two or three o'clock in the morning you
know like this is not no frat house
[Music]
you